[музика]
літо море переповнені пляжі попри
морській небезпеки і часті обстріли
[музика]
ховаємось конечно її ну однак якщо
тривога Що будете робити
якщо тривога Ну що як тривога то до Бога
після заходу сонця літнє життя не
припиняється
[музика]
Стоп
Я би залишився би на все життя би так
відпочивати
[музика]
це Одеса чи не єдине місце в Україні де
офіційно можна купатися в морі
в Одеській Ова запевняють що морська
вода прийшла до норми після знищення
каховської ГЕС нещодавно тут відкрили 6
пляжів і не виключають що згодом їх може
бути більше
Саме ці пляжі які вважаються безпечними
вони обладнані спеціальними антимінними
сітками вони обладнані боями з пляжів є
декілька шляхів у випадку наприклад
евакуації також ці пляжі обладнані
гучномовцями при повітряній тривозі щоб
люди чули що є повітря на тривога
вишками з рятувальниками Та нині люди
купаються і на дозволених і на
заборонених пляжах
військово-адміністрація не може це
зупинити незважаючи на те що заборона ще
була дійсно вона все одно вони все одно
ходять на пляж вони купаються пляжі були
під час спеки переповнені і замість того
що просто там спостерігати да за цим
обласною військовою адміністрацією
головою військової обласної
адміністрації Але гонкіпером після
консультації з військовими було прийнято
рішення що
треба убезпечити ділянки для
оздоровлення людей для декого офіційні
дозволи влади немає значення людей не
зупиняли Ані забруднене море а ні міни
що дрейфують не переймаєтеся про безпеку
там міни запливають чи щось таке я тут
живу я тут живу які мені міни на
французькому бульварі Я нічого не боюся
в серпні набагато краще ми були зі
середина мабуть червня ну якраз два
тижні після каховської трагедії гірше
було але було Менше народу звичайно
як же ну з моря там виносить Такі всякі
речі нічого там не виносило а трохи
трісочок та й все я взагалі родом з
Бердянську так що вона теж буває і
холера в 70-ті роки і ми мали Ми
купалися і Як бачите живий і здоровий Ми
з Миколаєва
тому ми не хвилюйтеся я знаю ваше
питання про небезпеку для нас Одеса це
дуже Мирне місто Утім чимало хто прийшов
на Цей пляж саме тому що тут офіційно
дозволили Купатися за три роки минулих
це перше ми на морі Ми одесити
до речі ну як ним відпочивають довіряємо
самі підстанції яка каже що мурить чисте
але так далеко не занурюємось перший раз
за літо взагалі до відвідав водойму тому
А ну не знаю позитивні відчуття от пляжі
були закриті не було офіційного дозволу
на купання От і ризикувати не було сенсу
от тому що Ну якщо вони закриті То на це
має бути якась причина цей офіційний
пляж мав би бути обладнаний за всіма
вимогами безпеки Утім сіток які мали б
стримувати міни відпочивальники не
помічають Я не знаю як сітка є трос які
натягнуті там десь Далі є буйки думаю що
сітки як такої немає
стрілки що вказують напрямок до сховища
дійсно ведуть до підземного укриття Утім
зазвичай воно порожнє
орендар одного з пляжів підприємець Юрій
дегас розповідає люди не зважають на
небезпеки
перекрити прохід до пірса але ви ж
бачите людям все одно ми їм кажемо але
народ настільки за два роки скучив за
морем що їх Мені здається нічого не
зупинить за рік до повномасштабної війни
Юрій обладнав платну зону для відпочинку
і безкоштовний пляж зокрема для людей з
обмеженими можливостями
запевняє що всі території для купання
огородження сітками дно щодня обстежують
водолази А на постах чергують
рятувальники
Поки ви Юля ми в липні практично тільки
відкрилися тому що з'явилася потреба і
люди почали ходити Ми не можемо просто
це кинути ходіть Як хочете Ми вирішили
це привести до ладу ще не було чіткого
розуміння буде воно чи ні але це ж наша
репутація порядок і краса але люди пішли
з моменту як Ова і місто дали добро що
можна купатися це другі вихідні як дали
роботу минулі взагалі було божевілля ось
тут неможливо було лягти ніде пройти
навіть неможливо було
Утім нещодавно ось це відео розлетілося
одеськими телеграм-каналами заплутані
антимінні сітки не виконують свою
функцію Юрій дегас На чиєму пляжі було
зняте це відео стверджує водолази
розплутують сітки і кріплять на них
вантажі однак речниця оперативного
командування південь Наталя Гуменюк
раніше заявляла що сітки не гарантують
того що морська Міна не здетонує
Одеський еколог Владислав балінський
автор цих кадрів теж не певен у
цілковиті і безпеці купання в морі має
на те й інші причини він регулярно
стежить за станом води в морі і життя
морських мешканців після нинішнього
занурення має невтішні знахідки Ось
бачите якраз в мене я з собою взяв Це
загибли вже гідробіонти це краби
декількох видів трьох видів навіть Ось і
ось бичок це вже
Скажімо так із-за того що температура
води дуже-дуже висока зараз біля 30
градусів фагота безвіна то є загроза
такого масового замора бо зараз у воду
потрапила з підривом каховської греблі
дуже багато біогенів це продукти
життєдіяльності людини це змиви з
полей Це
в тому числі
пестициди добрива всі вони є споживчою
середовищем Та таким для організмів
живих істот для мікроорганізмів і після
ось такого підвищення температури
починається масово розмноження і це може
приводити до таких масових заможних
заморних процесах кадри Владислав
фільмував Невдовзі після знищення дамби
каховської ГЕС узбережжя всіяне сміттям
осад з потрощеної деревини на дні мертві
молюски але наслідки відчутні й донині
хоча море біля Одеси вже Солоне тут досі
живуть качки яких разом з острівцями
очерету принесло з Дніпра в море
Владислав каже в морі нині рухаються
об’єми води забруднені продуктами
розкладання загиблих молюсків бактеріями
пестицидами якщо ми кажемо про відкриття
сезону То якраз ось
в серпні зовсім мені доречно його
відкривати бо Якраз зараз ну є загроза
велика або ще може тиждень і почнуть
дути постійне вітра вітри з боку якраз
гірла дніпро-букского лиману А це вітри
пасілят вплив саме
забрудненої води саме дніпро-буф
ерського лиману на нашого узбережжя
війна не дає про себе забутий у місті в
історичному центрі зруйнований
спасо-преображенський собор неподалік
морського узбережжя житловий комплекс у
який поцілив російський калібр
а неподалік музика танці атракціони
Одеса відпочиває поки є можливість
недорогі
апартаменти ми знайшли Ну якби
ціна не дуже велика мабуть із-за того що
зараз не сезон і за обстрілів частих
дозволяємо собі мінімум на все рівно
хочеться покупати у морі
і платіж в Приватбанку 50 грн кожен день
Я вважаю я можу собі дозволити Так
це курортний район Аркадія ззовні
видається що тут усе як раніше та за
словами місцевих до повномасштабного
Вторгнення в Аркадії було ще більше
людно й гучно здається мені що це якось
не дуже на часі Но а що зробиш життя
таке людям також треба відключатися від
війни бо якщо завжди
думати про війну то можна навіть крише
поїхати розумієте тут зустрічаються і
туристи і вимушені переселенці люди
живуть і відпочивають нічого тут не
зробиш Це життя діти потребують цього і
нам потрібно це робити для них
да ходи тихо трошки їх розвіювати бо там
важко і тут важко але діткам треба
відпочивати так а що тобі найбільше
сподобалося тут варкаті це море
так море люди
знімають люди трошки стрес знімають
можна так сказати трошки просто Ми за
два года почти два года войны ми за
майже два роки війни стомилися це все
переживати спати в підвалі спати в
коридорі
в коридорі вот Вот они ты спишь
ось в коридорі невдовзі кафе і
атракціони зачиняться до 11-ї вечора
Курортна Аркадія порожніє адже опівночі
комендантська година Ще одне нагадування
що в країні триває війна